hi Steve coffin here again to talk about
language learning if you like my videos
by the way please subscribe very happy
to have subscribers and do take the
opportunity to visit link which is where
I do my language learning but I'm going
to talk about language learning i will
talk a bit about motivation but i do
like talking about political subject so
i'm i'm considering actually setting up
a separate channel here on YouTube where
I would talk about whatever comes to
mind that's political but today I want
to talk about motivation based on things
that I've just experienced the last of
the while with language learning of
course there's the motivation that
initial motivation in other words to try
to get started with the language and
then there is the motivation to keep
going and I want to talk about some of
the things that influence that one thing
that I have said before there's an
expression in French which is La Petite
via on mah jongg which means the
appetite comes as we eat and I think
it's very important sometimes to try and
get started like I hadn't done any
polish for about five six weeks and I'd
kind of been putting it off and I
listened to my Russian my ukrainian but
haven't done any polish and and then i
noticed that the video that i did when i
spoke polish with my tutor had become
very popular in Poland when I got a
hundred thousand views and people
complimenting me on my polish so that
immediately motivated me I said jeez I
could get back to doing some poet but I
hadn't been doing it so at first it's
difficult to start up again but as you
start doing it whatever you do as you
get into it very often just if you put
that initial effort into doing something
then it starts to become a habit so
that's the first bit of advice is kind
of push against that initial inertia
stay with it for a week or so then
you'll start to develop
certain habits that make it easier for
you to continue so that was the one
thought i had on motivation and the
other one was the role of a tutor most
of my language learning as you know is
is listening and reading as you know if
you've been listening to me here is
listening and reading however I did
decide you know that okay I'm gonna go
back after my do more polish and so
again at link i went after some of our
polish members and asked them that they
would do some online discussions with me
so they said yes so then i started doing
this with them and what i find is that
whereas before that for like 10 days or
so i had just been listening and reading
if i've had a few polish discussions
where i have been made aware of the
words that I don't have of my mistakes
of my problems where I'm confusing poles
with Ukrainian with Russia having
struggled there there with those tutors
when I get back to my reading now and
listening I am more alert I am I notice
more so it's it's stimulating not only
do I want to improve so that I can do
better when I speak to my Paulo tutor
but also speaking with polish tutor
helps to make you more aware helps you
to notice better what's happening in the
language when you listen and read at
least that's been my experience so I
that's all i have to say i'd be
interested in any comments if some of
you have had similar experiences so
thank you for listening bye for now
you